another significant number of daily
cases with almost 180 000 reported in
the uk but new data from the health
security agency suggests the omicron
surge is beginning to shift first
geographically the epicenter has moved
from london to the northwest of england
with parts of lancashire and cumbria
glowing dark red on the map the new hot
spots but the virus may also be moving
up the age bands certainly in london
which has been slightly ahead of the
rest of the country
figures from the office for national
statistics suggest the proportion of
londoners with the disease peaked on
christmas day at little over nine
percent but they've been falling since
to just under eight percent on new
year's eve however that masks the
potentially serious demographic shift
prevalence has been dropping more
steeply in young londoners in those age
20 for example is down from a little
over ten percent to around six percent
but in the elderly although rates are
lower they're rising more steadily on
christmas day 2.8 percent of
80-year-olds had covered by new year's
eve it was almost four percent and
they're more vulnerable to serious
disease so who's being admitted to
hospital then well this is the age
breakdown around england in young people
admissions are flat but the blue line
here shows admissions are steadily
rising in the over 85s and you can see
the beginnings of a rise in the over 65s
in yellow the worry is that they're
already rising with a full effect of
high case rates over christmas yet to
come
now the government is betting on
vaccines to protect the nhs but there's
increasing frustration that some people
are still holding back
i haven't said this before
in this whole
vaccination campaign i just want to to
reach out to all those who
have not been
yet vaccinated and say it's a great
thing but i also want to say
to the anti-vaxx campaigners
the people who are putting this
this mumbo jumbo
on social media they are completely
wrong
only the booster gives a good chance of
preventing omicron disease but uptake of
the top-up jab is slowing in every age
group now in the over-60s rates have
almost leveled off at around 90 percent
but in the under 30s there are already
signs the rapid rise before christmas is
easing off with uptake still only at
around a third
the slowdown could be due to the festive
break but if it continues and rates of
serious disease rise still further the
government may have to rethink its
strategy